واو ، هذا ما كنت تسعله
، لم يستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً
حتى أدركت ليندا الساحرة الأعرج مدى
خطورة السعال الذي يعاني منه ، هل ستشعر بالتوتر
حيال الذهاب لتلقي العلاج بسبب
التكتل الذي لا أعرفه في الوقت الذي
كنت أتقيأ فيه  الدم كان أمرًا
فظيعًا ، أخبره الطبيب أنه لم يكن خفيًا ، 19
ما كان مصابًا به كان مرض السل ، وهو
مرض يقتل ما يزيد عن 66000 جنوب
أفريقي سنويًا الآن ، وبعد أسابيع فقط
من علاجه ، يستجيب بشكل جيد
وهناك الكثير من الأطفال أيضًا في
المنازل المفقودة  أنهم يقيمون فيها ، لذا فهذه
نقطة الخطر خطيرة للغاية ،
لكن العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية يحبون
التعامل مع الأجهزة المحمولة قلقون من أنه مقابل كل
نجاح مثل التأخير ، فإنهم يفقدون الآن
الكثير ، لذا لم يكن
هناك فحص هنا منذ بلدة سلاو ،
نعم الناس خائفون  من kovat
أنفسهم لم يرغبوا في أن نأتي إلى
منازلهم وأعتقد حقًا أنهم
يعتقدون أننا تسببنا في ذلك
لأنفسنا كنا نشهد
بالفعل تأثيرًا كبيرًا على الأرض.  عملت ليندا جايل
بيكر خلال أسوأ
انتشار لوباء فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية والسل في جنوب إفريقيا ، فهي
تخشى أن تضيع عقودًا من
المكاسب التي تحققت بشق الأنفس بسبب التركيز الذي تم
الكشف عنه 19 منذ أن أعتقد أنه كان من الصواب
أن يقوم الناس بالتحفيز ولكني
أعتقد ذلك  أنت تعلم أن هذا لا يمكن أن يكون على
حساب الأمراض الأخرى حيث
نعلم أن لدينا معدلات اعتلال ووفيات كبيرة كل يوم
، وبالتالي فإن الأمر يتعلق بنوع من
المشي والمضغ في نفس الوقت على
الصعيد الوطني ، يقول المختبر الحكومي إن
اختبار السل انخفض بنسبة 50٪ ، وانخفض بنسبة 33
٪  هذه عدوى مستمرة في
المجتمع وهو الشيء ذاته الذي
نحاول تقليصه حتى مع تسهيل الإغلاق على
الأشخاص الذين يستمرون في الابتعاد عن مواقع الفحص المحمول لفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية في
جميع أنحاء كيب تاون ،
قاموا مسبقًا بتغطية متوسط 30 اختبارًا يوميًا هنا الآن يخبرونني أنه يم
ن  ترى فقط حفنة من الناس
وتركيز جنوب إفريقيا النية جيدًا
ضد فيروس جديد قد يؤدي مرة أخرى
إلى ظهور أحد أقدم الأمراض في العالم
David McKenzie CNN كيب تاون